un silence étouffant
suffocant
juste le bruit du feu du vent
ce village de bil au gorille fca à l'est
de l'ukraine a subi plusieurs frappes
aériennes russes ici c'était une école
90 civils penser et trouver un abri sûr
un soldat ukrainien film les ruines et a
du mal à cacher sa colère
il ya très peu de survivants
salle aux russes
selon kiev il ya au moins 60 morts dans
l'hôpital voisin les rescapés sont
sonnés
j'ai été mis au sol par l'effondrement
d'une dalle je me suis recroquevillé
puis il ya eu une autre explosion
des pierres sont tombées
puis les ténèbres j'ai ouvert un oeil à
travers la poussière j'ai vu un rayon de
lumière sergei a rampé et m'a aidé à
sortir puis on a déterré mon oncle et ma
tante on a rampé dans le nuage de
poussière
et ce bombardement est loin d'être une
exception
les territoires du dombass encore aux
mains des ukrainiens sont sans cesse
pilonné ces derniers jours